اعلن الجمهور رونالدز سانتوس قبل قليل عن
ترشحه الانتخابات البيت الابيض وقال في
مقطع فيديو نشره على حسابه في موقع تويتر
انا مرشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه من اجل
قياده العوده الامريكيه العظمى وقد تخللت
العمليه الاعلان عن الترشح مشاكل تقنيه
واضحه
غلبنا الحقائق على الخوف والتعليم على
التلقين والقانون والنظام على الشغب
والفوضى لقد صمدنا عندما تم تهديد الحريه
اظهرنا اننا نستطيع اعاده احياء امريكا
نحن بحاجه الى الشجاعه للقياده والقوه
للفوز انارون اعلن ترشح الانتخابات
الرئاسه لقياده العوده الامريكيه العظمى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات